what if I'd uh mr. penny when the
theaters have all been closed down by
the plague oh by order of the master of
the Revels mr. fennyman allow me to
explain about the theatre businesses the
natural condition is one of
insurmountable obstacles on the road to
imminent disaster from the 1999 Best
Picture Oscar winner Shakespeare in Love
during William Shakespeare's career
theatre is closing due to plagues and
pandemics were regular occurrences but
there's something entirely new to
today's venues and kovat nineteen
shutdowns are putting the future of many
in peril MTS Tyee visited the replica of
Shakespeare's Globe Theatre in London to
see how they're determined to survive
with his timeless wisdom in it it was
Shakespeare who penned the now immortal
phrase all the world's a stage first
uttered in 1612 and this stage is a
nearly exact replica just a stone's
throw away from Shakespeare's original
theater he fittingly named the globe but
the globe of our era now sits eerily
empty a casualty of the coronavirus
lockdown that actress and artistic
director Michelle Terry has been tasked
to fix how do you keep your doors open
if you can't physically bring bodies in
to enjoy the artistry of Shakespeare
that's gotta weigh heavily on you yeah
if it's really hard it's really hard
because you're not just trying to keep
the doors open sorry
please please there is an ecosystem of
artists makers that we have educated a
huge education element to what we do
some of Britain's biggest names in stage
and screen are warning of a cultural
catastrophe without urgent government
support the UK's theater industry earns
around 1.3 billion dollars a year and
employs over 300,000 people all at risk
because of the pandemic
King Lear is one of Shakespeare's
greatest words was written during the
plague Fresh Prince of bel-air sitcom
star and respected classical theatre
actor Joseph Marcel has thrilled
audiences with his interpretation of the
role what needs to be done to save the
globe make the people the government of
England the the world understand that
this is something that should be
cherished that you should hold next to
your heart and the globe isn't alone in
its financial struggles but the
Playhouse is rare and that it not only
offers major roles to performers of
color well one kiss and it also draws
audiences long overlooked elsewhere the
globe was the first theatre in England
not only London where as an actor on
that stage you looked out and there were
black children if we if black lives
matter if the National Association for
the Advancement of color colored people
matters then the globe has to survive
because it is the one of the only
theaters in Britain that is constant in
supporting artists and supporting
artists of color yes if the globe were
to reopen social distancing rules would
require it to remain at least money
troubles won't go away
Michelle Terry says she's hopeful we
will make it safe and we will make it
possible but we are pack animals and we
are storytellers and we need to be
together and we have a responsibility to
make that possible
[Music]
in a space unlike anywhere else
for CBS this morning Saturday
India's time London MTS tyub I love that
story
save the globe Jeff save the globe
indeed hard hard to imagine the future
without for the globe